okay for those joining this livestream
this is another episode in our series of
internal design review meetings this
particular one is about a feature of us
and bought neural map framework
specifically this new function called
net evaluation function so the idea is
to provide a wrapper around neural
networks that provides for prepackaged
for properly packaged pre-processing and
post-processing is that correct yes
exactly um we have a template forward
the documentation page it's all good
okay there and how far have we got with
that before
I mean we laid down the design and now
we switch to use for function and the
prototype validation of interpreter so
there are like some needs an issue we
would like to discuss with you
by the way that format is not correct as
you know the abyss says to be updated
sorry partition return by
that seems kind of random then the body
of the description has been updated
today it's not the last version okay
I'll update it um okay but so what are
the design issues that we have here so
the most important one is that right now
there's no way in interpreter to specify
that you want an array of a specific
shape I have been when I say the in the
first second point in the agenda so it's
our wait a second so we're using
interpreter specifications to define the
this is kind of like the outer layer of
the encoder for the neuron that is that
right yeah correctly and it's that I
mean how does that relate to what we're
doing with the compiler type system for
example mmm it doesn't because that not
exposed yeah right now yeah but recomm
the only documented type system that we
have is interpreter yes I understand do
you mean my first draft was using
patterns but you were keen on using
interpreter types so we well I mean okay
are we sure that circular let's open
your page um
so let me understand what a typical one
of these would look like actually I have
a test no because this one is not in the
is not in the prototype build I have a
note that you can send it to you you
cannot run it but has examples on how it
works and it yeah okay but so but to
what extent are we expecting to actually
use things like the location interpreter
and so on as as part of the input in
that evaluation function zero so what
are we doing with it so we know it mean
it depends if you have a network that
that takes I don't know an image and
allocation and does something with that
it's actually up to whatever you want to
do okay but but so what is the point
here the point is we want to have a type
system to define what might come in so
that we can so that we know what our
encoder to use or the encoder yeah all
right we want to validate the into
before passing it and avoid that
anything breaks especially for the net
valuation function when we provide okay
it would be it would be met okay it's
fine but so this is okay so let me
understand the purpose of this so we are
trying to validate we are expecting to
actually pass the input through
something to a to validate or to convert
do you validate it's just a failure like
an interpretive failure failure if it's
not correct like this we know but we're
not interested in converting it even if
it is interpreters main job is to deal
with strings and that doesn't come up
for us
yeah I don't think it's relevant I mean
I just don't think it's relevant here
okay so let's take a look at what you've
got here for this there's some okay but
but actually a couple of things so first
of all
okay okay so what is evaluator it will
be the actual net evaluation function
that takes arguments the function and
does whatever you wanted to do like
pre-processing post-processing mapping
of the network well in particular no no
hold on a second what what what
specifically does it do because it's
going to have let's just look at what
this is going to look like so it's going
to be there's going to be eventually a
net evaluation function that's going to
have some kind of that's going to be
returned by net model and it's going to
have some kind of net specification
inside it it's going to have your
association that specifies various
things it specifies it should specify a
preprocessor a post processor and the
actual network isn't that correct
processor is everything inside the
evaluator it's general objects this way
but I understand it but it's going to
ultimately it's going to take some input
it's gonna take the actual input to the
network I I don't understand it says
okay next question is this trainable or
not or is only the net inside it
trainable only the net is trainable
inside it's not just one like sort of
layer that goes like a net encode your
net decoder you may want to take one
network map it on the input and then use
another network and then combine the two
so it leggings in certain pipelines you
have more elaborate yeah I understand
but then why that's the single thing
called net here sixteen networks and
exactly there's not just after that the
same one can also be in a social of
multiple networks or layers why do we
want to even distinguish the net then
why isn't this just a general function
because it's nice for the user to be
able to queried and to see it okay so
this is a little bit so why is this not
a net model this is the output these
would be the output of some net model
calls but why isn't net model why
doesn't net model have in it
pre-processing post-processing functions
the other time is because you may use
different length models or I mean net
model is be tricky to use it multiple
networks well so no let me give you a
different answer net model is trainable
whereas this isn't in general yes it's
also true the network so yeah you can
model is not ahead like we did I mean
you you came to the realize it you know
like you originally suggested what if
this was their very loud
sorry no no I can't hear him at all in
fact missus yeah sorry telly so this is
a general program right and I think it's
nice to have a repository output that
because it's a small thing instead of a
pure function but for the custom one
what is really the added value of having
it compared to pure function we we want
to expose how to build these things
because users will be able to submit
models to normal as we go and so as this
will be a part of its part or is it okay
when you okay so what is the workflow
here so there's a net model which has a
name right and that name is being looked
up in the neural net repository right
yes and what it's returned from that is
a network yes right okay now do you also
imagine that there are net evaluation
functions that are returned by the
neuron that repository or whatever yes
then they're not trainable well they
will have a trainable part which is one
or more networks and then they will have
you know some extra water lemon language
code whose needed for oh wait a second
wait a second right now by the way do we
have Meghan in the school
let's if if somebody can find her that
would be good
okay I go to okay so I'm still I'm very
confused here okay
net model is supposed to be the thing
for accessing the neural net repository
except now you're telling me that the
neural net repository might contain a
net evaluation function so net model
okay so what you're saying is net model
instead of returning a naked net chain
it would return a net evaluation
function wrapped around a net chain is
that correct yes but so then we have to
tag which of the networks directly in
the neural net repository are directly
trainable and which are not all the
networks are trainable is it understand
what's being returned here look normally
that the workflow will because a net
train of something which you get back I
mean what hi
so there's an uninitialized what the
trainable thing would typically be but
it might not be it might you might want
to train it from a state you already
have here isn't that correct
yeah this what we say it like we with
those keys we still provide you with the
network's uninitialized or or
initialized yes basically do we do we
document somewhere that you are
guaranteed that you can plug a net model
Internet train because I don't think we
do yeah we don't well but should it be
the case yes but on the other hand there
are very interesting models which
requires you to add additional code
running besides the pure no I realized
that I realize no no yeah I was thinking
about that I mean this would be like net
train looking into this and taking out
the pieces you know that can be also
multiple networks so but it's not going
to that's very unlikely to work to be
able to you know you know in the current
state of the world not every program is
trainable and you know we kind of have
to so so then what will actually happen
if you call I mean if you call that
train on a net evaluation function what
is it gonna do just generate they are
message
what you mean the same one you get if
you don't provide the better network so
all right just so you know like net
model already privileges evaluation of a
training so we the default content
element is the valuation network which
often can't be trained or it can
directly be trained fair enough you have
to stay uninitialized about you know
evaluation network or something to have
something trainable but maybe we need a
different key in the net model to have a
trainable thing there is I think there's
a train train Network we often don't
have the Megan do you know I'm just
technically you mean a Content element
of the object yes the uninitialized one
is the untrained okay there should be of
another field we haven't added it yet
but we discussed it already this
evaluation net and this training that
but we haven't added training that yet
the training that will be the one with
the most layer for example exactly you
have a los honores
but none of the models as a training
nets right now yeah okay okay so let's
let's loop back here to what we're
talking about with that evaluation can I
make it a general seeing story about the
purpose of net very function I mean it
seems to be a very specific thing like
visiting pure function to run a veneer
network in it I don't know I feel that
maybe we could build something more
general and I mean is there a real
reason why won't that work only for
networks or you know as opposed to just
to like a pure function that would
format well yeah but you know if you
want to go more general than these it
just become more from language code like
it just becomes the function opposed to
me and somebody said it was too far away
and we want this now
I mean I'm also I'm I'm also super not
convinced about the design and that's
usually when
multiple people are not convinced this
is universal right so okay so look let's
talk about the function repository okay
so the function repository is going to
have these things called resource
functions I mean it's it's not going to
be here for 11:3 but it is coming soon
and a resource function is something
with which you know comes from a
resource object the resource object has
metadata the resource function is the
wrapper that actually is for evaluation
a resource function typically has some
kind of representation that looks a
little bit like an entity representation
does that make sense to people now I
mean it can contain anything but let's
take a look at what let's take a look at
the use case all right so the main issue
that we have is in here when I mean when
we have net model okay what is what is
being said is that net model in order to
be useful for evaluation net model has
to have additional functions wrapped
around that go beyond just the net chain
and so on
that correct for some models for some
models I understand wait it's a
challenge that because net model is not
an object that model is purely a way of
retrieving arbitrary data from the
repository
no I agree I agree but the net model the
the evaluation network what what is
being called right now the evaluation
net you know we could imagine having a
thing called evaluation function that
was part of what comes back from net
model and we could imagine that
evaluation function is actually the
default of what comes back from that
model not that's what we designed last
time that is this thing as far as I
understand okay so are we imagining then
that there's an additional content
element in the resource objects for the
net for the repository is that right
exactly exactly
definitely it's called evaluation
function which is normally what would it
normally be it would normally just be
the identity function it would normally
for a network that is pure net chain it
would just be the pure net chain
redirect to the evaluation network or
maybe it could just be none because we
can select for each resource what's the
default content element I think I guess
it's a point if you want to have like
that it's if you say net model without
any second argument it defaults
alternatively information network or
evolution function or it's always the
full simulation functions it always
refers to evaluation function but that
may turn out to be just a just a naked
in the TV I don't know if something that
always runs yeah that thing might be the
same as the it might just be the same as
the evaluation net okay now what is it
so what's a typical example of a wrapper
that we want I mean again we've also got
a pass through options like
probabilities and things like this right
yeah they often have options we have a
way to call it in the valid syntax when
it does not put errors right now the
evaluation function just F but that one
is taking the network like the input one
option and a list of properties and the
list of properties is fast as a second
argument similar to what classifies
function is is doing so you can say okay
function of these comma probabilities or
miss the probabilities the classes okay
but so I'm trying to understand what
what is the typical give me a specific
example of an actual wrapper function
used for a real case we already network
okay what is the for now we're
distributing it as role model so if you
know you can go to the to the net repo
website basically it's a network that
provides you with the chromaticity of
the the two chromaticity channels and
you have to take which process and color
color net imaginations as well yeah yeah
just take just take a look at the
example notebook so you see that this
thing is tagged as role model because it
in principle it needs an evolution
function but we don't have that yet
okay so where is the evaluation function
I mean do you give it any yes it's a I
mean it's just a variation function this
thing here okay so this is a typical
this is a very simple one yeah it's like
a toy model but you could imagine for
example matting and network over list of
strings this is something really
something that this will be the first
real natural action function that we
will have fine all right so let me just
try to understand then okay I get it
so the main issue then I mean to put
this in as a function in net model so
that it is you know so what comes out
here I see so the issue is you can't
have this actually this has to be
something you know there is a potential
you need it not being evaluated yet you
need it being held unavailable because
what you want here is you know so in
this case yeah right but but well also
the pure function wouldn't be so okay so
that's basically the thing you want
correct okay in this specific case
because it is the optional it has no
property it's a very that it doesn't be
specifically that would be the evaluator
key of the naturalization function
I don't think it should be called
evaluator I think it should be called I
mean if it if it is anything you know
okay so you're saying the pre-processing
and post-processing is all packaged
together here yes because in general you
want to be very flexible there are a lot
of cases in which you don't have pre and
post-processing back yeah but would it
be convenient to have those as keys and
then to have an overriding you know a
lower-level key that is just the
arbitrary function I mean in other words
sometimes it might be useful to be able
to see this is the pre-processing this
is the possibility yeah I mean it would
be something but it would be still very
complex because is it the function what
if you provide multiple arguments then
you have to pass the station to the
preprocessor and then how does this
apply so your concept would evaluate a
function how does it it passes in
association with I mean if you specify
that the arguments are like the low
image and the length it will give you an
association with image goes to value
length goes to number okay what you
imagine is that net evaluation function
despite the fact the most net models
just eat a an arbitrary expression
you're you're proposing that net
evaluation function typically eats an
association is that right I mean we
don't especially if there's only one
argument they eat that thing which is
what we also do if you have a single
argument you can just pass it directly
without destination but if you have for
example net graph that takes has two
ports you have to provide an association
with two inputs and that's what's
happening right now with yeah right now
yeah we just copied the design to be
like known confusing means already
confusing we're trying to make it less
confusing as possible okay so hold on so
so the issue so what you're imagining is
by the weight somebody on our live
stream with a I'm guessing Japanese um
user name says if you're looking for a
use case for location type input it
could be an inverse of that network I
think it network we'll be talking about
earlier take a location input and
synthesize an image that looks like it
comes from that location okay that's a
that's a cool idea
or style transfer
location to an existing image that's a
cool idea based on for example the hour
that is a that's a cool idea I don't
know whether there is such a I mean in
inverting basically our um wherever it
is our network for this one here
for finding geolocation so you provide a
location you get an image out yeah be
cute the UM
but anyway that's a case where the input
might be a location for what it's worth
I mean might be it might be convenient
to have an actual interpreter with
something like where you can feed in
Eiffel Tower as well as geolocation this
this um alright so so let's come back
then so what you're saying is you want
to have let's say this net evaluation
function and you basically want to have
in it I don't understand this so so this
is I mean this is for some kind of error
checking purpose this is to pre you know
so that we can when you build there I
mean we need some way to build one of
these function because if you want to
expose it if we don't want to expose it
it's fine but if we want this to be a
phone that a user can upload a net model
that contains one of those it has to be
clear how to build them and so you have
some how to tell this object you are
going to see these kind of arguments
you're going to see you're going to use
this network you are going to use these
properties well but you're going to use
potentially many networks and I don't
understand why I mean look what you've
got here seems like a very reasonable
way to set this up which has a network
you know embedded inside this function
it doesn't distinguish the network angry
it seems like a complex framework for I
don't know four four little things on a
network example if this example is a bit
toy
so take machine translation so the
evaluation function it has to take the
the network it has to then do surgery on
the network to separate the encoder and
the decoder well they wouldn't they
would probably need inwards to begin
with rather than having to separate it
in the function because whatever either
one then there's like then you have to
have arguments like what does the beam
search size like there's an optional
arguments it's gonna generate it's gonna
call it the net it's got a lot of code
in it yeah the question is you know what
we really want there the
main issue is that we like the fact that
net model produces a displayable thing
here the second thing that let's imagine
that we had in that evaluation function
here what would we actually display so
in the modern world what you're
proposing is that if I bring up the
prototype build if I'm not mistaken you
you are proposing this initially closed
yeah you're proposing this thing here
right this initially closed
representation of a net chain for
example all right John
yeah so what you want is something I
mean the question of whether you can
display explicitly if you're not worried
about displaying it explicitly just a
piece of code like any other piece of
code and you don't get to display it
explicitly but it will just run right we
can return a few function yes so but the
only issue is that you want something
that you like the fact that this is
visible and displayable but as soon as
you have a complicated piece of code
like like even this it's not going to be
visible and displayable it's just gonna
be an arbitrary pure function how you
should operate it it's like not self
documenting at all unless you mean you
can always read the code but no no no no
but I mean well it's like like anything
else I mean it you know functions the
function plot is not self documenting it
has documentation and the documentation
that's all you want we're not going to I
mean this if we are gonna have
documentation for every Network that's
what the neuron that repository does
that's its role is to document these
networks
yes Matt it will be much nicer if you
have you write you know directly in your
notebook without having to go to the
website and see sure it's it's nice to
be able to query that stuff okay because
we believe somehow I mean you know we
could imagine that every function I mean
every function does have this is very
confused if I might say so I mean in
far as you want flexibility you can't
have it be structured that is you know
every function if I say you know poster
mark plots it's gonna give me some
documentation for how to use plot now do
I want to be able to have a programmatic
version of this which we haven't really
needed you know I mean this you know
Wolfram language data gives you a
programmatic version of that for what
it's worth right I don't think people
use this all that much but you can get a
programmatic version of how to put
arguments in after every function and so
on
make sense
yeah let's let's look back again to what
it is we really need what we what the
real issue is what does net model
actually return when there is a more
complicated evaluation function needed
for this model is that right yes
couldn't we see I mean yeah an emotional
question is what is this net repository
about is it easy to repository of
function that are enabled or easy to
read something returned networks so you
can train on them so you can do surgery
so you can use it you know and merge
them and do another network and then the
function we kind of be a secondary
aspect right the brain plugins is to
deliver deep learning functionality
because we have a long wait for that we
doing notify we do I don't no longer
translate and so on maybe the
functionality are really for a long wage
and and the role of the repository is
really to give networks my disagree so
if there's some technique that for
whatever reason we don't want we haven't
yet put into the system or we may never
put into the system because it's too
specialized but it still requires that
you use three networks in a complicated
way it's very nice that someone can
that's basically kind of what people
would be doing on github now but they
package up in it okay but they could do
that by asking a specific property of
net model to get the function like it's
not like it's not there and it will even
be documented but I have a feeling that
if we if it's important enough that we
should put it straight away in the net
model maybe it's important enough to be
in the long word as well no but okay
look the other point is we would be
having a different conversation if we
had if the function repository existed
right now correct yeah and maybe that's
there I think we should wait for that to
be finished finished but then we should
also be very clear about what our
requirements are so that the function
repository doesn't turn out to be
something else
because if it's going to be something
else then we repository is is we could
get people in this meeting who are
actually working on finishing the
in repository the function repository is
is you know well in progress
I mean what we could do right now is in
net model we could imagine having an
element here I don't particularly like
this but well we could have it we could
have the element you know evaluation
function which is not the default add
more elements right John yeah they don't
have to be the default and not we're not
tied to that I think and then then that
could be given arbitrary you know given
the thing that contains so that will
contain in addition the pure function
that does the pre and post-processing
and all is good so what I think so going
back to this thing about what the
purpose of this whole thing is so the
one thing that I hate about pure
functions is that you can't see easily
what they're doing so one of the most
important things that this has to do is
that if you just have a random net model
and you don't know how to evaluate it on
data that's pretty useless like you want
to be able to see okay here's how what
the valuation procedure looks like yeah
well fine so then you want
but-but-but what you want then as you
want some key here that says you know
input structure or something and it will
be the same for each was function right
I'm not sure we don't know function look
resource function just has documentation
because it's a general function I think
it's really important to just say
there's like three or four features we
really want Sebastian said one can we
listen to others otherwise we go ahead
one is a description of the inputs and
what types they have and validation of
those types well I think validation is a
bonus which we can you know that's nice
but I think that's a bonus
fair enough okay
next there is optional but I think this
is zero thing if I might say so which is
the you know the wrapper function for
evaluation
the wrapper function from innovation the
function that you want to actually be
using for the evaluation of the network
the payload yeah of course right that's
the function if we can call that the
function payload but there's another
payload that's the data payload so there
might be one or more nets no there's not
no I I don't agree I think that this
function simply calls this is where it's
gonna get totally messed up right
because a single net model okay is a
single network right now yeah yeah yes
this will extend it to have you helped
us design that in the last meeting yeah
exactly where that we extended it is
that evaluation network instead of it
mostly will be a single network it could
also be an association of networks okay
because we'll the evolution function key
may have a function that contains again
net modern with another key that is one
of the things I was concerned about but
I mean it doesn't have to it can contain
naked networks you know net graph net
chain etc I mean it shouldn't because
then you gonna download this thing three
different times and it's the same thing
underneath if it happens that it is has
a dependency on another network that is
exposed in the neural net repository
then great it can use that model but if
it uses its own custom three networks
then it should just have them right
there in the in the actual net model we
saw the evolution functions is will be a
pin function that would wait maybe yes
even we don't want that because it means
if you ever asked for snippets then
those networks separately you will have
to download another gigabyte and it's
the same girl okay but so are those
networks separate do they have separate
entries in the neuron that repository
you know will different keys but it
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
look if you can't refer to them okay
then look if if those networks if those
sub networks are themselves things which
are independent resource object
then great they are cashed separately
they can be referred to by other
functions etc that's one way of doing it
but that's not what we settled on last
time I mean I just want us to recap what
we settled on last time ok we'll remind
us ok so inside the pivot I mean you
could do it two different ways the way
that we discussed last time is inside
the pure function if you want to call it
a pure function yeah call net model of
yourself comma evaluation net and
there's your net by yourself how would
you specify that what it actually looked
like it's the name it's the name that
you are oh my gosh okay okay the second
option is that the name followed by what
the evaluation network that's that's not
the that's not the thing because that's
the whole evaluation network what if
there were six evaluation networks then
it's an association and then you can
subsequent you can subscript it easily
because it's an association there's no
problem with that you just do open
square bracket of part one and then
later on you Joker's could break it
apart too and so on I don't really like
that I mean I think if we're gonna do
that then we should have evaluation net
now how should this work then then we
would have an association that this
evaluation net should be an actual
network shouldn't it it shouldn't be an
association of networks why not if in
the rare case that there are multiple
networks what better way of the I think
it should be a separate okay let's keep
going with what you thought we figured
out last time right so that's one thing
that's the wraptor function and then
this this immediately separates the
underlying data from the wrapper
function the wrapper function is is pure
code and then the data is living the net
model in the way it always has then
separately well just a second just a
second okay gone gone gone yeah yeah
this is a digression as originally was
supposed to describe what we wanted from
the system one was validation one was
property there's an optional property
that you might want a lot like if
there's a default output and
there's a way of modifying to get a
property okay
so there's like garner not outputs eg
probabilities right okay um that's good
and then there is and this is important
there's optional there's options that
you can pass in when you evaluate the
thing and they they have the chance to
be passed to the wrapper function yeah
that's another thing you can't do with
the people with the Mathematica pure
function ah this is a mess I mean I
think this shows that we need seven
thing I mean this probably will be
needed in other circumstances then for
new networks and of course I mean the
resource function is one example of them
so I don't know I think this calls for
generic way to end and link that to
create a pure function that make it easy
to have these things and also for might
well you know I mean it's what I want
from from the function repository right
what we get from the function repository
so things you have getting go ahead in
order to make it more general the only
thing you have to do is to remove the
net key and change the name of the thing
basically yeah but then we shouldn't
reinvent the function I'm also with the
TN may be the right choice here is to
wait a bit and as funny was saying just
be super sure that we are ready to
interface with the function repository
when when this is in a usable State well
okay so what we would do right now is we
would have an additional key called
evaluation functions that is a pure
function there's a pure function that
calls this net model in the cases of the
you know comparatively few networks
right now where we need some sort of
more sophisticated pre and
post-processing but then what do we
expect the final state of this to be we
expect the final state to be something
where this neuron that repository is
purely a repository of neuron that's
that have the feature that they can
always be you know that they have this
this very definite structure they would
sometimes refer to I mean this is the
you know function repository can
perfectly well have a section I mean
nobody cares in the function repository
whether functions a B and C work with
you know computational geometry or
machine you know or neural nets or six
other techniques right
they're just doing what they're doing um
and you know I think that that I think
part of the point here is that we are
explaining that you know we're
supporting neural nets for the sake of
having one be able to do sort of work
with neural nets just like we have I
mean look we could say for our data
repository we could say well guess guess
what we don't just want data in the data
repository we also want functions in the
desert repository but that would be
silly you know the data repository is
just blobs of data and then you get
functions that manipulate that data in
different ways so I mean the original
discussion here was about a design I
mean this is a completely separate thing
this business about designing
generalizing repeating element
mechanisms to deal with arbitrary depth
tensors that's a that's a perfectly
valid thing to do but don't think it's
urgent unless we're trying to use it for
this purpose yeah we just brought it up
because it was needed here okay so
listen I think what we're concluding is
that right now given that we are you
know about to freeze the system for the
next version that we should just add an
evaluation function element to net model
and use that in the cases where we have
to use that does that seem reasonable to
people yes
function poster is coming for next
version absolutely yes yes I mean and it
will be good to get a presentation for
you guys also function repository to
make sure that actually has the features
we need but let's just talk about the
evaluation function here is the
evaluation function going
to refer to the current net model
because in the construction notebook how
is it going to refer to the current net
model which has not yet been been
created so to speak when they when the
construction notebook is is constructed
well you can strap the Nets so you can
refer the net will be something some
variable in that notebook and you can
use it
nobody shouldn't do that I think you
should call net model directly to
retrieve the net inside the pure
function otherwise you even one two
copies isn't it sorry said again I said
the pure function I think should I mean
that I feels is obvious it should
contain a call to net model right that
won't evaluate because it's a given no
no I understand I'm simply saying at the
stage of building the construction
notebook and maybe Megan can speak to
this maybe there's a maybe where they
have a mechanism for this in the data
repository I know yo-yo in fact we do
don't wait for the when you construct
examples you refer to the net model in
some symbolic way when you're doing the
construction of the notebook isn't that
correct yeah so it's called something
like dollars all a model or something is
that right yeah it works like dollar
dollar object for the resource object
and then dollar dollars data is like the
resource data okay all right fine which
in this case is the net model correct
yes yes okay so then we can use that
here so that I might my concern about
building the thing you know that's okay
I think did that make sense to people
it's just you have to be able to refer
to the net model before the net model
has been created as long as it's clear
that the final one will have explicit
net model
string a comma yes it will just like
just like listen when when you create
the examples okay you don't write net
model of blah blah blah because that has
not been created yet you write Dollar
Dollar data here and that is converted
to net model of blah blah blah but what
did you want to use it to argument for
is it
I mean is the dollar dollar data going
to be okay I don't think that'll work
then yeah I understand it's not gonna
work in that case so we need some
mechanism I mean it just needs in the in
the build process for the repository we
need some mechanism to deal with that
does that make sense
yeah and we need to figure something out
right because I mean you know in
principle the evaluation function could
refer to itself for example yeah be
particular about it yes right by the way
we have a question from our livestream
have we considered merging the neural
net framework with a more general pure
function application layers are just
fancy functions with types and hidden
parameters what is actually useful as
updating its parameters to through
training procedure building computation
graphs with them in other words is it
possible to treat any function as a
layer and make it work somehow the
answer is we're absolutely working on
that the issue is that in order to be a
valid layer you have to be able to do
certain kinds of no differentiation and
so on on the function you also have to
have it be able to work efficiently in
GPUs and so on to do training and that
requires that we have some level of
compilation of the function and we are
working on precisely that and hopefully
I don't know where the actually the I'm
curious what have you been
does anybody can anybody comment on the
status of customer layers the statuses
with waiting on the compiler so as soon
as the compiler is ready then we can do
custom it and have you been interacting
with those guys to get to see what
pieces already because there are pieces
there ready
I mean there's some plenty of stuff that
can be compiled have you have you
actually tried to see what's involved in
putting it all together I mean don't you
have to do automatic differentiation and
things as well as just pure compilation
so this is two things one is we can try
and also differentiate with symbolically
first and if we fail to do that then the
user has to give a derivative expression
mm-hmm so that's one thing yeah
so it's an optional thing the user gives
a gradients to the case we should be in
a position to do something right now
because the compiler can certainly deal
with things that are you know a very
wide range of things that are
symbolically differentiable yes so we
decided that yeah like posts this 11.3
freeze we're gonna push this and also in
feature that we also want as the GPU
support and that's they've told us that
it will take a little bit longer to add
that um
okay all right we should we should wrap
this meeting I think our conclusion here
is evaluation function
is the new key that will add we will use
that to implement these you know sort of
beyond neuron that networks and we will
simply show in the examples how to use
that potentially tricky you'll need to
sometimes will need to use module
like literally module of X equals
whatever right yeah those symbols that
we introduced in the module have a
context and that context should probably
not be global but if it is global it'll
look nice if they look at the pure
function it's not global to look ugly
but it won't pollute their namespace
they cannot cross that bridge right now
their module variables let's simply not
cross that bridge we're going to have
the function repository soon enough it
deals with all of those kinds of things
everything what do you want do you where
should we put the symbols in in a
function I don't think you should have a
a I mean the question is should the
neural net repository at the build stage
have as it creates symbols at the build
stage have a begin package thing in it
and my answer is probably I don't think
so right now but if you want to have a
better understanding of that talk to
Rick Hannigan who's working on the the
function repository because he's got a
solution to that I believe okay okay but
I do not know yeah I'm not sure I think
we should I you know they got him in
module if their module variables they're
localized anyway don't worry about
putting them in a different context I
think I'm supposed Lobel will at least
look nice it won't look horrible yeah
and I don't think I think these are
gonna be these are cases where this is
part of a do-it-yourself kit anyway this
is not intended to be you know the the
resource functions eventually will be
the things that are not do-it-yourself
kits
and I just intended to be you know fully
lady production really yes so you know I
think I think that's the right thing for
this okay anything else for right now
right here
well one concern with this may be what
happens from the case in which you need
multiple networks for the same model I
think the common case is is put into the
neural net repository the sub networks
as their own separate networks ok and if
necessary they will be and if there are
a lot of these there'll be a bunch of
networks I mean like for example if we
look at what's there already there are
some networks here which are you know
which could reasonably be I don't know
whether are these all end-user networks
I don't know right now they mostly are
isn't that correct yes let's go so ok so
but we can certainly imagine something
and I'm surprised like like Daniel
George's networks for example for signal
processing are they here yet or not no
there are some there have been some
licensing problems with the university
which are taking awhile to to get
started ok fine
the UM but but um ok but in case there
are things there that we you know that I
think are more neural net component
models so to speak that are intended to
be used with other things that aren't
necessarily end-user models and maybe
we'll end up with you know maybe
eventually we'll have a section here
that is called you know component models
or something that contains things which
are not which might still be useful on
their own but which are not intended to
be immediate and user neural nets does
that make sense I mean it isn't it ok
here's a question
it's go ahead this case is exactly words
for a certain internal functions we
definitely do this already like this
top-level functions that call a net
model and we're not gonna expose that
that model to users it's just an
internal thing sorry sorry I I supposed
to threatened cuz I'm sorry so we have
we have certain for things like find
faces for example we might have and I
think there's already some examples of
this where yep there's neck models that
not exposed to users they're just like
the new facial features as many marks
model and some of them are exposed some
of they're not but let me go in
different place when they're posed to me
fair enough that I mean okay fine so I'm
will have will have a thing for
component models so to speak that might
or might not make it on to the you know
that this front page will eventually get
reorganized when it gets too big and you
know there may be a section called
component models that most people won't
really care to look at but people might
find useful to browse you know because
they want components for something else
they're building all right I think we
have a path forward so yeah great
all right